there's a whole lot going on in Mortal
Kombat 11 and it can be overwhelming but
we're here to steer you in the right
direction and offer some quick tips to
help you become a savage fighter here
are 12 things you should consider to hit
the ground running do the tutorials and
character lessons NetherRealm Studios
has gone the extra mile by making sure
fighting game beginners and veterans
alike can efficiently learn the ins and
outs of MK 11 thanks to a robust
tutorial not only will you learn about
the different strategies for certain
situations of a match but it will also
walk you through the more complex
fighting game mechanics like the frame
data of movesets
zoning escaping pressure and a whole lot
more study move list data beyond the
tutorial itself each character's inputs
for special moves and combos are
available in the move list with all the
frame data and damage numbers included
this helps pull the curtain on
information traditionally dug up by more
seasoned players like start up speed
recovery time and frame disadvantages
when blocked all that information is
readily available in menus for every
single character's moves
don't waste your fatal blow MK 11 has a
new comeback mechanic called the fatal
blow when you're down 30% health or less
you're granted the opportunity to
perform a fatal blow by pressing both
triggers simultaneously character
animations will vary but if you can land
it the fight will transition to a quick
cinematic style combo that deals
significant damage you're only allowed
to land one per match so use it wisely
and don't waste it on the first round if
you don't think you can realistically
make a comeback fatal blows can also be
blocked so consider using it in a combo
for a guaranteed hit
make use of the offensive and defensive
meters most fighting games have you
building up a meter in order to unleash
special attacks but MK 11 does things a
bit differently by giving you two
separate meters for offense and defense
you start each fight with them full and
they automatically replenish at a fixed
rate amplifying certain attacks expends
the offensive meter which results in
extra damage additional hits or the
opportunity to extend combos performing
breakaways for defense will let you
escape juggles and get back up faster
with a window of invulnerability put
together some combo strings to maximize
your damage output you'll want to learn
how to create combo strings it's routine
for most fighting games and MK 11 equips
you with the knowledge needed to
experiment yourself mechanics like
launch attacks to set up juggling combos
stun attacks to make opponents
vulnerable and amplified attacks to
create windows for extended combos are
the keys to better combos as detailed as
the tutorial is it won't spell out combo
strings for you but it does give you the
tools necessary for executing advanced
combos customize character variations to
your liking MK 11 features more
customization options than previous
games you can pick out your favorite
special moves pieces of gear and stat
changing augments to create your own
variations for characters this allows
you to get creative and combine
different elements of a character's move
set but also tweak how they behave in AI
fights cosmetics aren't tied to stat
changes like injustice to so you can put
all that gear you've gathered to use and
make fighters look the way you want get
familiar with preset variations to play
competitively while you can tinker with
the many aspects of each character when
you make your own custom variations
you're restricted to two predetermined
variations when playing ranked matches
online be sure to use these presets and
study what they're capable of to stay on
top and MK 11s competitive matches the
different currencies and how they work
coins are awarded for pretty much doing
anything in the game you use coins to
open most chests in the crypt which can
grant you cosmetic gear new animations
and moves
flair for your combat card among other
things soul fragments are another type
of currency acquired by winning matches
you can begin spending these once you
obtain airmax
amulet in the crypt which is used to
open green chests or repair the bridge
on the island hearts are another
currency earned by performing fatalities
and brutalities in matches these will
let you open another type of special
chests in the crypt towers of time
challenges and crypt chests also reward
you with these currencies to help
accelerate the process time crystals are
a form of premium currency that can
either be purchased or earned in
specific challenges these allow you to
straight up buy things in the premium
shop like character skins and new intro
or taunt animations as it stands the
price of items in the store makes it
fairly difficult to buy things by solely
grinding for time crystals use our crypt
guide the Crypt has changed quite a bit
this time around it's now a sort of
third-person adventure mode where you
explore Shang Tsung's Island solve
puzzles and spend in-game currency to
open chests that unlock extra content
longtime fans will also come across
plenty of references and easter eggs
while exploring like Goro's dining room
in mataró x' horn grind at the towers of
time at the end of the day the towers of
time is the most efficient place to
grind for currency and obtained gear
towers consist of a series of fights
with specific sometimes wacky conditions
and modifiers you won't see anywhere
else in the game for example you might
have to win two rounds in a match while
your opponent only needs to win one or
missiles will randomly shoot at you
throughout the match and deal
unblockable damage modifiers widely vary
some of which might be frustrating to
deal with this is also where you use
consumables which are a variety of stat
boosts or attacks you can summon to give
you an edge or even the playing field in
the more challenging towers if you find
the towers of time to be more on the
frustrating side then we suggest sending
in an AI Ally to do the fighting for you
daily challenges are another way to get
currency when you pull up your combat
card in the main menu you can see a set
of daily challenges on the left so far
these have been fairly simple tasks like
winning a certain number of matches with
a specific character regardless of
difficulty and opponent
completing these challenges reward you
with in-game currency like a decent
chunk of coins story mode is great
and gets you a good amount of coins do
it MK 11 story mode brings you into the
series's lor with self serious yet
ridiculously fun cutscenes and player
driven fights
you'll get acquainted with most of the
games roster and their backstories
throughout the story modes twelve
chapters in addition to being a wildly
entertaining ride with a ton of great
moments for a longtime fans and
newcomers alike
the story mode awards you with a lot of
coins and some cosmetic items to get you
started on the customization process
what else would you recommend when
starting up MK 11 let us know in the
comments below and thanks for watching